[Music]
hey good folks we have a happier themed
show today
our first caller is from los angeles and
wants to know how to safely get off her
anxiety medication
we talked to the husband of a previous
caller from another show
he wants to help his wife with her
depression i called him out and he
called me back
and the young woman from utah wants to
know the difference between gossiping
about family
and just keeping everybody informed
we're smiling on this one stay tuned
hey what up what up it's delony welcome
to the dr john delony show
shows about you your lives your
relationships your families your
relational
and your mental health all of it right
we're here in the shiny new fancy
fancy pants studio and we are walking
alongside one another trying to figure
out
what do we do when things are going well
what do we do when things are
falling off the map what do we do when
we just don't know what to do next
well give me a call give me a call here
at 1-844-693-3291 that's 1-844-693-3291
if you are new to our band of ninjas
here we talk about
everything on the show mental health
challenges family and relational
and iq questions we talk about mental
health issues
i think i already said that right we
talk about school challenges we talk
about everything
everything you can imagine give me a
call 1-844-693-3291
give me a call or go to johndaloney.com
show fill out the form and we will check
it out
so we're going to go straight to the
phone today we got a packed show today
we're going to go straight to the phones
let's
go to sarah in los angeles california
sarah what is going on how are we doing
how can i help
hi dr john doloni i was actually
listening to your podcast while standing
my kitchen cabinets and now i'm talking
to you so it's a pretty
exciting day it's an exciting day for me
too thank you so much for calling that's
awesome
hey which show were you listening to was
it a good one or a dud
well they've all been good for me so i
was it was a good one
that means you and my my mom and one of
my old college roommates are all in on
this show so that's pretty rad
very cool thank you sarah sure
i was hoping to ask for some of your
guidance
on weaning off those anxiety medications
um
and also some encouragement um i
read your book recently which i really
enjoyed and
gave me lots of things to think about
and did inspire me to be a lot more
militant
about taking care of myself physically
um very cool
but uh uh one of the things that you
know caught my eye was when you were
talking about anxiety medications
and your philosophy really is very
similar to my own and that
i never intended to be on
anxiety medication long term the hope
was always to get on some medication
help me to do my work and then lean off
of it
and i was reading your book and looked
up and realized that i've been on
anxiety medications
for three years this is not
short term i think i don't think this
qualifies anymore
and yet i have been i feel like i've
been
doing the work um i feel like i've been
on this really long
journey trying to become healthy in like
every way possible
um and uh and yeah so it was just really
discouraging to
look up and realize i've been on
medication for three years i still feel
like there's
so far to go i'm not sure how to
think and plan for what to do next
because i
didn't actually start out with
something concrete about what i was
going to get to or maybe i just need
like an arbitrary deadline to work
forward so that i have something to kind
of go towards
i don't know but i would love to have
some of your advice well
number one thank you for the kind words
about the the book
um number two more importantly thank you
for investing in yourself and being
excited and curious about
taking new steps to continue on your
wellness journey that's so rad
and i'm just i mean you're making me
smile right now sarah this is awesome
so walk me back you know looking through
the lens that i talk about
in that book that anxiety is an alarm
man and it is letting you know
that something in your ecosystem
something in your environment
is is making you not safe something is
is alarms are going off for because your
body is remembering things that happened
a long time ago and something in your
environment
is reminding you of that that you are
out of control or that you are
lonely and disconnected where where do
your alarms stem from
oh man um so i
know there's been so many um i mean
there's
the one that i've been able to recognize
is just um a lot of shame
um or just like fear of what people
think of me
um just i don't know there's so many
that i've worked on for over the years
um but i uh but the funny thing is that
i have like a really awesome life
and i love my life so much i have this
amazing husband i have this like
awesome kid i have a job that's
stressful but like really meaningful and
i am
with good people but i just find living
it hard
i like really love my life but living it
is so hard
so what makes it hard what makes living
at heart sarah
ah um
what you just said is a really really
profound statement
and i hear that a lot
and it seems like one plus one should
have equaled two
the perfect husband and the perfect kids
and the perfect job
and the perfect body and the perfect
fill in the blank
equaled happy right and it doesn't what
do i do
um yeah i um yeah
i i don't know yeah so like living yeah
i i've always
so i've always found existing always
feels really hard like
just like um like i never it's very very
rare for me to feel
peace um it's uh
it's very yeah that's just always been
very very hard it just like always feels
like
i'm tense um do you come from
do you come from abuse as a kid your
parents still together
uh so i actually come from a loving
family that had challenges
so my um my mom was
loved us to bets um but she had her own
problem
she grew up in a in a post-war uh
society um and um
yeah like she was she was very uh
she wasn't very stable emotionally sure
um
so i i do know that that is something
that i
uh have that stem that does
uh kind of is the source of a lot of
things
what about you what about your dad oh my
dad
he oh he handled things by shutting down
my poor dad um my mom became very very
ill
um when i was younger and he just didn't
handle it very well
and handled it by shutting down um so
can i tell you
can i tell you just in in five minutes
of talking to you
okay you handle it by
peacekeeping
you handle that
that part that six-year-old girl that
four-year-old girl that is so desperate
to have her mom look at her and say you
are my one
who is so desperate to have her dad say
crawl up in my lap and we're gonna read
a book we're gonna do a puzzle and i'm
gonna
um we're gonna have a pillow fight and
we're gonna eat ice cream until our
eyeballs fall off and i'm gonna make you
go to bed
even though you don't want to the way
you handle that
permanent alarms that's been going off
since you were young is you make sure
everybody else is okay
and you have crafted perfect life you've
crafted it you went and got it
and you are finding out what millions
and millions and millions of us in the
western world are finding out
that this recipe for quote-unquote
happiness
is failing us the recipe of getting
stuff
to fill in this internal gap this these
tethers that aren't connected and that
aren't rooted um
it doesn't work man so our our our you
know our
frontal lobes our thinking part of our
brain does what you just did it kicks
off
all the blessings in our life all the
things we've worked our butts off to get
all the games we've played to get what
we needed to get
and in the back part of our brain that
little amygdala is still going
help help help i'm not connected i'm not
connected is that fair
ah i've never thought about it that way
so it's gonna take me a minute but
i am just i'm on for the journey
the the way you process is so like
wow you might be the smartest person in
the room and i'm going to need to think
about this
hey here's a good idea sarah you may be
the smartest person in the room too
and my guess is you've never allowed
yourself to have that thought and it's
probably true
and i feel embarrassed just listening to
you say that
no exactly and the one thing you caught
me on a second ago was when i said
you've got a great husband and great
kids and great
whatever john we're all things i rattle
off and you've put together the perfect
body i've never seen you but you stopped
me on that one
right don't look at me let me be in the
background let me make sure everybody
else is okay
because mom needed to be okay dad needed
to be okay
and that repeats itself over and over
and over and over
okay so a couple of things before you
got on medication have you seen a
counselor have you worked with somebody
who's a professional before yes um about
the time i went on medication i
jumped into searching for one so i found
one that i i really
i feel like a good relationship with are
you are you still seeing that person
i am okay and so three years later
have you sat down with this person and
said i am ready
to stop living a life of anxiety i want
this part of my life over
um i mean i i think that's what
i've been that's been always the goal
okay but i do think
that you um i have through listening to
you
and you talking so much about rejecting
anxiety as an identity
that's something i have been thinking
about a lot and it made me think a lot
about i think my counselor
went on a little bit more of a
roundabout way about that um she talked
about like
the default mode network and like
rejecting the default mode network and i
was like i think this is the same thing
yes i often i often say it's it becomes
a default setting it becomes an excuse
for right so you look around your house
and you've got everything's perfect you
look at the mirror it's perfect and then
your
your body still doesn't feel whole and
so then you're able to go
oh yeah i have a defect
that a medicine will fix for the rest of
my life i'm good and you know who that
really
really benefits is pharmaceutical
companies
right but you know i'm sorry the reason
why i'm having a little bit of a
disconnect in the conversation
is because i so don't think that
my life is perfect i just sure you're
like it's really meaningful like my body
like i have
all these stomach issues that are almost
certainly related to anxiety there you
go that's right
like break oh i've like i i don't know
how to use my body correctly so
exercise has been really challenging
like i don't know like there's nothing
about my life that it's like
and and hear me say sarah when i'm
saying that your life is perfect i'm
speaking
i'm speaking in hyperbole for the
listener here right i'm speaking to
those of us who are checking just get in
a habit of comparing all the things that
we have with
this internal system that's letting us
know hey you're not okay you're not okay
you're not okay you're not okay you're
not okay
and normally like we talk about in the
book we either moralize it and say oh
you
ungrateful idiot or we say oh it's just
cause you're broken
you're broken and you need to take
medication for the rest of your life and
it will fix it
and here we are right there you go and
so what i want to give you another
option is
is it's not an identity it's something
to listen to
and so to get back to your original
original question are you still meeting
with a psychiatrist regularly or are you
just now
on a they just refill it by text or some
simple you don't have to go in anymore
yeah just refill it i i did um from your
book think that i do need to find
somebody
uh i was going to a kind of an
institution that's well known here
but what was happening was i was being
followed by residents that were
turning over so i think i'm gonna have
to find somebody who
is gonna be consistent there you go and
so
um i will i will walk you through um
what i did to get off of the medications
and i'll tell you i worked closely with
a doctor
and he he's again i'm privileged here
because he's a friend of mine
and he made fun of me because i
my my i was so obnoxiously gradual even
to the point that he said i need you to
know that how gradually you're getting
off this stuff
has no physiological consequence meaning
there was no nothing biological about my
how i weaned off
he said you're this is purely
psychosomatic
this is purely a placebo in your head
but if this makes you feel better go for
it and i said it it does
so a couple things number one is getting
with a doctor and letting them know i've
been on this medication for three years
and i want a a definite exit strategy
and i want us to partner together
as i exit this thing and so let's say
you're taking 25 milligrams of x then
the he or she will say great um
what are the lifestyle changes you're
gonna make right and so
for me a couple of important important
focuses are
and these are just basic stuff sleep
finding out how to sleep became
cornerstone numero uno matthew walker is
the sleep guru
that meant eventually got to a place
where
um i have to be almost
obnoxious about not being on social
media or screens before bedtime
i was obnoxious about supplements that
helped me sleep i was obnoxious about
not exercising too late too early i
tracked
my sleep pathologically almost like
insane and but i dialed it in and now
man i can sleep on a dime
and it's really a gift and except for
the occasional night i don't and what i
used to do when i
was really in the throes of this of this
anxious season was
a night when i knew i could you could
tell at ten o'clock eleven o'clock
you're not gonna sleep
um i would just flip out and i would get
nervous about it and i would amp myself
up and then i would be over think it now
i just get up and read a book
i don't lose no pun intended i don't
lose sleepover not sleeping
because i know i'm going to catch up the
next night right and so it's just giving
myself some grace the second one is
a an acute focus on
movement on exercise on walking
you've got to get outside and move your
body there is
all kinds of research from the movement
part of it that
helps your brain to the vitamin d part
of it that we are all catastrophically
suffering from
vitamin d deficiencies to all sorts of
down
um it literally changes your hippocampus
in your head
exercise does and so um you mentioned
you had some body challenges so i would
talk to my doctor
about what are some exercise programs
that i can do
um and then a unrelenting
emergency every alarm should be flashing
in your head
um you've got to get with other people
i say all i say this regularly to the
point that
the folks who work with me give me a
hard time about it the only true
quote unquote cure for anxiety is other
people
is relationships is connection with
other folks and that ends up being
the hardest thing especially in some of
your situation
you had two people on planet earth who
were who were
tailor designed for you to connect with
and that was your mom and dad and they
didn't
and that sucks right yeah
and so i think about it that way that
was their only job
obviously to fit to food and to feed and
clothe you but their job was to connect
with you and they didn't
and so you have been your poor amygdala
has been running
for your whole life and if you if you
listen in
today's geek minute we're going to talk
about how um
the inflammatory effects of some of
these what we call mental health
challenges
they just wreak havoc on our bodies for
years and years and years and years and
they cost us
all kinds of downstream challenges when
we suffer these childhood traumas
like mom was not well like dad just
shut down again it doesn't mean they
didn't love you doesn't mean they
weren't trying the best they had with
the tools ahead but that does mean that
you've got some skills that you need to
pick up on and so with your counselor i
would be
hyper direct about i want to learn how
to be in relationships and i want your
counselor to help you set up some
situations where you can be in
relationships
i want you to get with that awesome
husband of yours and y'all be
intentional about hosting people in your
home or you going out to
be with other people i want you to be
hyper intentional about connection
does that make your heart race or does
that make you excited
oh i that makes me excited i have a
really great community
around me and anything i do think that
with
coronavirus it's been a little more
challenging but i just have to
you are the greatest understater that
i've talked to it's a little more
challenging
no it's been a diarrhea
blizzard it's been awful right terrible
it's not been good at all um or it's
it's been not so good right in the words
of sarah from los angeles
um but yeah i want you to oh sorry
go ahead the nurse and my husband i was
gonna laugh because my i'm a nurse and
my husband's a public health inspector
so our
work lives have gotten like oh
i can't even i would love to be a fly on
y'all's wall that's right
hey and and also know this um how long
have you been a nurse i probably should
ask you that before we even start this
whole conversation how long have you
done that
uh since uh almost 10 years now okay
does that job bring you joy or does that
job spin you up
um it can do both but usually
um over time i've learned how to do my
job
in a healthier way and a big thing was
i uh went part-time and that actually
made a huge difference
okay i enjoy my job much more immensely
now
and uh and also just yeah just like i
think
learning physically how to take care of
myself better because one thing is just
uh unsurprisingly i have a really really
tough time with sleep
um and so that uh improving on that has
made my ability to
handle my work life much better very
cool um
well number one as a nurse thank you for
your service you guys have
have you men and women have just gone
above and beyond above and beyond the
last year
you always have and you went
unrecognized but this past year
you've been the true true heroes
recognize
working in trauma again let your brain
know
hey we may not be safe and what you deal
with every day as a nurse is
everybody else's that's probably not
gonna happen
and you deal with it day after day after
day and it begins to reset your default
setting
two things are probably again i'm gonna
end up on tubes i'm gonna end up in a
hospital i'm gonna end up with someone
having to
help me go to the bathroom i'm going to
end up in all these places right and
again
your amygdala all its job is to sound
the alarms and you're not safe when
you're not connected
and so it makes my heart feel full um
that you've got a good community that
you can lean in on
okay so quick review how do you wean off
anxiety medication it's different from
everybody
but it's really important do not under
any circumstances if you're taking
any kind of meds just walk in and quit
that's a terror dome dude
don't do that there's some real true
um awful um biological and physiological
consequences that can happen when you do
that don't do that work with a doctor
to wean off and be intentional about
saying i want to make some strong
lifestyle adjustments i've been working
on this
and i want to begin to reduce my intake
on a wean off of this medication
work with your counselor specifically on
skills
specifically on skills how do i breathe
through this
how do i have enough courage to tell my
boss i want to go part time
how do i work really hard with my
husband so that i can get out of debt
um so that we don't have to work
full-time or that we can have some
breath
we can take a break understand when
you're in a bonker season like you
married to a public health official have
been in los angeles california for god's
sake
i can't even imagine what y'all been
doing and then real quick you've got to
focus focus focus on sleep
make that such a priority that
everything in your life revolves around
figuring out
what works for your sleep schedule your
sleep hygiene
you got to got to got to move and
exercise you got to be connected with
people
and it may be even as much as something
simple like
diet and i say simple that's a whole
other conversation
i've got somebody close to me that was
struggling with anxiety and
so much of it was dialed back by just
putting
uh decaf in the like cutting the coffee
because we you know they were pumping
themselves full of caffeine caffeine
caffeine caffeine so much
and then they they're they're they were
mistaking that for this anxious feeling
really they were just buzzed out of
their minds
and having decaf turned the turn the
volume down a little bit and
it made everything much more manageable
and then occasionally there's
supplements
um that work for folks and they're all
over the place from
you know melatonin to cbd oil to all
kinds of stuff that can help folks out
um magnesium and stuff and so get with
your doctor and walk through those
things particularly but
um i am man sarah you're a light
and i'm grateful for you and took a
little bit longer on this call but i
i'm grateful for you i want you to let
me know how this journey goes with you
i want you to have the courage to speak
boldly to your counselor and your doctor
and
head into a season without medication
and here's my last little thing
if you try it and your alarms spin up
and they spin out
and you end up having to go back and
take your medication for
another season you're not a failure
you're not broken
you didn't screw something up i want you
to keep plugging it
your identity is not an anxious person
your identity is not that you're
busted your identity is not in your
anxiety diagnosis
right it's just an alarm system that's
it that's all it will ever be
don't give up on yourself all right so
let's
i've got to go to this email it came in
and it reminded me of a conversation i
had
at my house over the holidays and it
also reminds me of
conversations i have here at my work so
the email comes in from connor
how do i even get my head in the right
place to start
planning my will the thought of dying
scares me but i know this is important
so this comes into the dave ramsey
office and they were like hey we know a
guy that can answer that question
the thought of dying scares me but i
know it's important
so over the holidays i sat down and
talked to my dad
about the fact that he's gonna die and
he talked to me about his will
and my mom's will i talked to my mom we
had a big family discussion about it
hey mom you're gonna die what would you
want your funeral to look like
and she's like whatever y'all want and i
said no you have to tell us
don't put this on us please because then
we're going to fight about it i'm going
to want to have poison songs and pantera
songs and
my sister is going to want to like do it
the right way and all that kind of stuff
right
and we talked about it and it was half
smiling and half very serious but in our
house and again i'm blessed my dad is a
homicide detective we've just talked
about death since i was a little kid
and that's probably why i had to see a
counselor but it's gonna happen
we did a big study uh a few years ago
and we
came up with a startling conclusion a
hundred percent of you listening to this
are gonna die someday
it will simply happen it's going to me
too
um there's this awesome guy out there
watching the show
him too james kelly zach i don't know
about kelly
kelly may be able to buck the system 100
james
and zach they're gonna die right you're
gonna die gonna die
i'm for sure gonna die it's part of it
right and i'll also say this not
everybody can talk about death oh
and then me and my wife part of our uh
annual retreat
we redid our wills we got on uh
a will thing here that we have here at
the ramsey office
uh will program mama bear wills and we
redid our wills together
and we talked about you're gonna die i'm
gonna die someone's gonna have to take
our kids someone's gonna have to and we
filled in the blank
we want to have the guitars who do we
want to have whatever and we went
through that whole thing
so i know that i'm blessed when it comes
to that conversation because i've talked
about death with enough people
over the years to know that for most of
you it's super
awkward this is not an uh
a this the fact that you're gonna die
not having a will
that is not an optional thing we have to
stop
talking about not having a will or i'll
get to it
my friend john king he's my best friends
on planet earth he said it best the only
reason to not have a will
is if you hate your wife and kids the
only reason to not have a will is if you
hate your husband
and you want to make things you want to
make life awful for your children
if you are single the only reason to not
have a will is you want to torture your
parents and your friends
it's just inexcusable and it's
now it's so cheap you can do it online
it's just
inexcusable you have to do it so here's
the thing
most of us go through life avoiding hard
conversations we
avoid him at work we avoid him with our
the person that we're in love with we
are avoided with the person that we are
crushing on we avoid them with ourselves
this is an easy one because we're all
gonna die
right it's it's easy but not easy right
like oh lose weight just die and
exercise cool and that's a trillion
dollar industry right
most people deep down crave real hard
conversations they just don't know how
to start them
so here's a couple of quick tips number
one plan planet
make a plan if you are single call a
friend over
if you need to get a glass of wine or
two and some trashy food i'm giving you
permission to order a pizza one night
you're going to have rocket gas the next
day but go for it
invite them over and say okay i got to
do a will i want you to do this with me
we're going to put on some music we're
going to laugh our way through it
if you are married or you're about to
get married
if you have kids you've got a
you've got an emotional a psychological
a spiritual whatever
all al obligation you want to say you've
got to do it
so plan the conversation tell your wife
tell your husband tell your fiance
next week on friday we're going to have
a date but we're going to talk about
we're gonna do a will i'm not doing a
will having a will does not make you
die quicker having a will doesn't make
death more imminent
there it yeah it drives me crazy
you gotta get on the same page right
you're going to have to have
conversations like hey who's going to be
the executor of our will
who's going to take care of our kids
who's going to be the power of attorney
how long do you want to be on
a ventilator how long do you want to
phil in the blank you got to have those
questions right
so here's what i want you to do the
ramsay folks here that i work with they
came up with this awesome thing
text legacy l-e-g-a-c-y
to three three seven eight nine i'm not
trying to sell you nothing
this is just i'm tired of people dying
without wills i cannot tell
you how many people i've sat with and i
looked them in the eye
or held them as they are shaking they're
crying so hard
and their husband or their wife is dead
in the next room
or it's being wheeled outside on a
gurney and they look me in the eyes with
a look
it is a very unique look and they say
the words
what am i supposed to do now
if you've never helped somebody try to
get
county funding because they don't have
any money
to bury their husband because
the money is there was no will and so
it's going to be all tied up in a mess
you've got to do it you've got to got to
got to and if you're young and you're
listening to this
get a will get it i don't care how old
you are how not old you are
text legacy to 33789 you're going to get
a free how to talk about your legacy
guide
they're going to push you to mama bear
wills and
please do that please do that it is so
cheap it's so easy you will check it off
your heart and mind and that's
all i'm going to say about it um all
right let's go to adam in
waco texas all right adam what's up
brother how are we doing
oh i'm doing pretty good today john i
was calling then you
say you had spoken with my wife uh katie
of
exactly what it was um but we have the
four kids and she's been dealing with
um frustrate or um depression issues and
i'm perceived as being frustrated which
isn't necessarily gonna be far
off um with it
but i also kind of want to get your
opinion on how can i make myself more
emotionally
available for her when she goes through
these spells
all right so before before we go any
further adam
easily the coolest guy i've talked to in
a long time
okay i don't know what kind of husband
you are behind closed doors
but the but here's the thing i called
you
out on this show which goes out to a lot
of people i thought i was just going out
to my mom they gave me some
numbers the other day it's a lot and i
your wife called in she who said she was
struggling with depression
and her she was frustrated that her
husband was frustrated about her
depression right
and i called you out i said why don't
you have him call me
and then dude here you are you called me
this is like high school when i'm like
once you have your boyfriend call me and
then you knock on my door you're like
hey what's up bro i heard you talking
about me so this is it adam and
the fact that you're from waco texas and
the fact that you can't shoot me from
there makes this conversation
way easier right but i want to
just straight up acknowledge that
there are there are just not a lot of
guys of character like you
who want to support and love their wives
who are willing to put it out there
and who are willing to be vulnerable and
say man help me out if you
put your money where your mouth is big
guy and um dude i'm grateful for you
adam it's a very
you're very impressive young man cool
cool deal
all right so how can you help your wife
give me an example of something
that is frustrating when your wife is
having a depressive
episode and it's just frustrating give
me an example of that
well um with that
an example would be like um she gets um
real big emotions um with the depression
and stuff
and for me is i'm not a person of big
emotions
so to me i'm just i guess where my
frustration comes from is i
have a hard time comprehending what
all's going through i'm one of those
people like i see a problem here's a
solution
execute done and
i i guess i'm at a um
i just don't understand
what she's going through with her big
emotions um
an example would be yesterday morning
ended up waking up freezing cold
i go to get up before everyone else uh
turn the heaters on in the house to warm
it up
i can't find the lighter for it
i end up asking her if she knows where
the lighter is and she kind of goes into
a little spiral first thing in the
morning
about not knowing where the lighter is
and then she's apologizing to me
about i don't know where i moved it i
don't know where the kids did with it
and i'm just
and my mind was like i was just asking
if you knew what the lighter is i wasn't
accusing you of anything like that but
then it kind of started her off on a
bad day and i just i don't know sure and
that's the
kind of example you're talking about i
love it
so hey let's so let's let's just dig in
on that example man
and um man
i just love your heart okay so here's
the deal
this is a common common thing we've
talked about a lot on this show
we will continue to talk along about it
i'm gonna speak in big broad
generalities and so if you don't like
generalities
send me mean emails or youtube comments
if that makes you feel good
most or a lot of men
are trained they are socialized just
like you
okay just like me and that is
there is a problem let's just solve this
problem
using a chisel and a hammer and a saw
and data and a fact and then uh
an achievement ta-da let's move on right
yep and so when somebody that we love
and that says loves us comes to us and
says
i'm so sorry i am feeling this way
and feelings and emotions and feelings
and emotions
your first thought was probably oh god
almighty dude i'm just asking where the
freaking liner is
go back to bed what are you doing and
then it's i'm so sorry and then you're
like
what are you sorry about stop being
sorry i just asked if you know the
lighters you know the lighter is man
and then it turns into this whole thing
how that conversation went okay
right so um
particularly somebody who has a history
of trauma which if i remember correctly
she she had some some some
some demons that have followed her
through most of her life is that fair
yeah yeah she had some early childhood
there you go
anxiety she's got yeah she's got some
stuff
um she's got some stuff back there um
it may be that a man early in the
morning
saying hey where's this boom
that sets off that alarm and man it
ain't coming back
and you and i will probably never know
where that alarm
originated from where it started from
but i can tell you this
sometimes that that alarm is chemical
sometimes that alarm
is hyper-emotional sometimes it's
physical sometimes it's all of it
and so what i want you to do in these
moments is to
not default to advice
data or facts okay
i want you to think of your wife not as
a problem to solve
but as a person to be with and this is
going to go way against anything you've
ever been trained or taught okay adam
so here's what i want you to do the next
time
something spins out because here's what
i remember from the last call
you love this lady don't you absolutely
you married her you have a kid i think
with her with your own and you adopted
her other
three kids is that right correct yeah
yeah and i remember her telling me that
you loved her
and if i remember correctly she really
loves you is that right
oh absolutely shows it to me every day
okay so
the next time you are just buzzing
through the day hey where's the lighter
and then she flies up in bed and you
know
you know her enough to know now oh here
we go
i want you to walk over and say give me
both your hands and i want y'all to
watch this when it comes out on youtube
y'all can watch it together that way you
know
that she's gonna do it with you i want
you to sit down by her
and grab both of her hands if that's
safe for her and if it's even if you can
get away with putting your hand on the
back of her neck
and holding one hand or putting your
hand on her face
and i want you to look in the eye and i
want you just to look at her for five to
ten seconds that's it
okay and i want you to breathe as calmly
as you can
and then i want you to tell her i love
you it is all good
and um i appreciate you trying to think
through if you knew where the lighter
was
but i got it from here i love you and i
want you just to step out
okay and the more you hover and look and
she's gonna interpret those as judgments
because her brain at that point is
scanning for any possibility of
disaster any possibility of discomfort
any possibility of not
safe even to the point that her brain
will skip
data for close enough he just raised an
eyebrow that probably means he hates me
he's pissed off right and you're like
what are you talking about just sneezing
um that there's some wiring issues right
and i hate machine metaphors but that's
the truth um
her brain's just the it's set off there
and then i want you to
encourage her to ask her hey would you
be willing to save up some money
and see if we can go to one of these
family counseling services here
because i want to know ways that i can
love you better and i'd love to get a
professional here in town
and hopefully she's working with a
doctor on her depression she's working
with a counselor
i don't remember exactly if she did but
i encourage her to go get one
i want you to say i want to learn some
skills meet adam i want to learn some
skills on how i can love you
and be the best best best husband we
we are here now we love each other so
good i just don't have any skills in my
tool kit i don't have enough wrenches
and hammers in here
in fact all i have is a wrench and a
hammer and this knucklehead on the radio
said i need to learn some more stuff
and so i want to take you and i want to
do it and i know we can't afford it but
we're going to scratch and claw and
figure it out how to do
it and then we're going to go learn some
new skills together and what you're
going to do because she needs to learn
these skills how to connect to
she needs to learn that you are safe
safe safe safe
and that's going to take trust that's
going to take practice and then what
you're going to do is you're going to
double down on connection
not facts not oh my gosh you're going to
lean in
to that discomfort that oh here we go
you're going to you are going to go
first adam you're going to grab both of
your hands
tell that you're safe you're safe you're
safe and then i also want you to do this
i want you to start taking care of some
what i would call the ons and the offs i
want you to ask her what are the things
that just bring you the most joy in the
home
and i want you to when you get up to
light the furnace which again you're
such a great guy adam
when you get up to light the furnace in
the house to make sure everybody's got a
warm morning when they wake up
if there's still cups in the in the in
the kitchen get those
if there's some clothes that your kids
left out grab those real quick i know
you work your butt off brother
i know you do but do those little things
start looking around for ways that you
can make her home feel safer
and safer and safer and man that's such
a gift so here's what i want you to do
after you have gone to a few family
counseling sessions after you try
a couple of times to lean in hold her
hands hold her face
look at her eyes and say hey hey i love
you i love love love you
and we're just going to sit here for a
second
and then once you get up and then you go
find that stupid light or wherever it is
i want you to call me let me know how
that goes okay you guys are awesome i
love y'all i love walking alongside you
and katie this is so cool
and again i appreciate you being a man
of character but i want you to call me
back and let me know how that's going
all right let's go to one more call
let's go to crystal and provo utah
crystal what's up hi thanks for taking
my call
thanks for calling in how are we doing
what can i do to help
i'm good thanks so my question is we
obviously are coming you know down off
of our holiday high if you will
from you know being around all our
family and our friends
for those of us that were you know
fortunate to be around them
but my question is when does it
become necessary for us to have like
healthy boundaries
around what you know most families would
consider small talk
whether that's you know talking smack
about each other
behind each other's back and you know
the general criticism that often
comes with with families and so that's
my question is when
when does it become too much when does
it become
something that we need to have healthy
boundaries around
man that's a lot i it's a lot because
you're calling me out because
it's a sport in my family too to make
sure we comment on who wore what and who
said what and how who so is doing and i
know they do it about
me and that's just kind of the sport um
and i'll tell you it's not right it's
not good
and so the reality is when families get
together
especially
i don't know i don't know i
families get together and they like to
talk about each other because it makes
them feel better about
what they're doing we got the same set
of genes dude look how good we're doing
right g-e-n-e-s not j-e-a-n-s
um but gossip makes you feel better
right and it comes with judgments
if i i would be or you should have oh my
gosh did you see what she could you
believe she would not just shut or he
would not
oh and we do that for one reason because
it makes us feel better
right and so i think
information is direct without commentary
and it usually comes with
planning and support right like hey man
did you see tommy
look he's doing well i'm going to reach
out and call him um
not because oh my gosh it's because he's
been drinking so much and because he
doesn't
oh he doesn't bathe and he's we don't
need any of that kind of stuff right
and so man that's so tempting families
talking about families is a sport it's
been going on for millennia
right um and it doesn't solve
anything other than to make us feel
better for a second but that doesn't
even work that well either
is that fair yes absolutely
so in your house what part of that can
you control
do you have brothers and sisters moms
and dad who's talking crap about who is
everybody talking about everybody
pretty much yeah yeah so
you could be the rock star and i'm going
to follow your lead here crystal
by when brother calls and says could you
believe mom
you can just go whoa i might talk about
mom anymore mom's mom
and we love her and we're just not going
to do that and your brother be like oh
cuz you're so great and be like yeah i'm
just trying to talk about mom anymore
and then when sister calls and be like
dude brother just called me and says
you're totally freaking out crystal and
be like uh i'm not talking about him
either
i'm talking about brother i love him he
doesn't bathe we all know that but let's
just move on right
and you can choose to set the tone for
i'm not going to be the person in that
family that talks bad about other people
in that family
i'm not going to use them to
artificially inflate my ego
for the tiny little snapshot until i've
got to talk about them again so i can
get another hit
is that fair yeah yeah that sounds
fantastic crystal if you do this it's
going to be hard
and if you do this it will change
america
literally because what we need people to
do is to start looking in the mirror
and start making changes there and then
to start making tiny little changes in
their home like hey we're not going to
talk about each other anymore let's just
stop that
we don't need to we love each other and
if we're gonna
get onto each other make fun of each
other let's do it in front of each other
which is a sport of my family as well
and we are awesome at it
it come to it's hard to believe i'm the
quiet guy at the table by the way
our house is awesome um it's one of my
favorite places the sporting is so good
um but then when families start just
stop
just stop and they take care of each
other and then you know what happens the
street changes
your neighborhood changes your cities
change and then
the dumpster fire that is the news these
days may look a little bit different
it may look different but it starts with
you saying i'm not gonna talk about my
family anymore i'm just gonna stop
i love them they're goofy all families
are i'm goofy
and now we're gonna move on i'm not
gonna film my day with that nonsense in
that trash so good for you crystal
um you may everybody called in today
makes my heart feel good man
this is like good the feel good episode
we finally got to 62 kelly
zach and james before we got the feel
good episode this makes my heart feel
awesome
all right so we're gonna wrap up today's
show i asked
somebody in the office that works back
there with
me and our team and i said hey
you're younger than me by like half um
give me a cool
best song ever and she was like oh my
gosh it's super this
and i listen to it
we're gonna go with it we're gonna go
with it judah and the lion from the
folks hop and roll
album out in 2017 it's called take it
all back 2.0
sounds a lot like mumford and sons with
a twist so i'll give it to him way to go
jude and the lion
i think these guys are awesome actually
um take it back
take it all back 2.0 it goes like this
hey
my life is real great i feel i'm well on
my way to my dreams coming true and i'm
getting to do it with you
and it feels so nice when the people
sing along they're singing along with a
banjo
i don't know that line but it's awesome
and the chorus goes but i take it
all back take it all back take it all
back just to have you
you'd know i'd take it all back take it
all back just to have you
and i'm waking up and i'm waking up
but i'd take it all back just to have
you that's a love song jude and the lion
good for you guys i like it
i would take it all back too and this is
an hour you've just spent with me that
you can't take back
this has been the dr john dolone show